[Inaudible].
It seems like you.
Who have owned and use extremely well
vulnerability as a superpower of sorts on your show and quite possibly
elsewhere in your life.
Let's talk about one question.
Opponent of that, which is addiction. When did you first.
First think of yourself as having a problem with it?
Any type of substance abuse or substance use.
Uh, throughout my using, but I had a different point of view,
which is my heroes at that time were Bukovsky, uh,
they were other romantic drunks. They were Waylon Jennings. And I,
and I had this, this fantasy,
this romantic fantasy that I could do something artistically that would be
impactful enough that it would excuse all of my shittiness, right?
So like Wayland's got several songs,
basically apologizing for cheating on his wife.
And it's hard to be in love with a fun loving man and Bukovsky would put these
books out and it kind of excuse what a horrendous piece of he was in his real
life. So I think I very much was I was looking to be a up,
but, but maybe one that was funny enough that people overlooked it,
or I wrote something important enough that people would give me a pass.
And so that was kind of my, my fantasy. And on some level it worked a bit,
I think people were willing to be around me more than some other people that are
less funny,
but I had underestimated that I ultimately
suffered. I ultimately was, uh,
demoralized and pessimistic and,
and defeated in that. It really wasn't about all the people around me.
I could keep in my orbit that I ultimately
had to be with myself all the time. And,
and so I had an awareness that I drank too much. That was quite obvious.
And I knew that I used cocaine far more frequently than the surgeon
general would recommend. And I,
I didn't care until, you know,
I had a few attempts at getting sober and I could put together two or three
months.
I generally did it because I knew I couldn't use the way I used and work in
movies. And I cared more about that. So I would generally get sober from movies.
And then in between movies, I would, I would go out. Um, but I had, my,
my most profound moment was, uh, I was about to start this movies a thorough,
I knew I had to get sober for. I thought, Oh,
I'm going to go to Hawaii for a week vacation with a buddy before I start.
Cause I know I'm going to be getting sober.
And I specifically went to Hawaii because I,
I was under the impression they didn't have cocaine there.
It's very hard to get cocaine there and I, I didn't want to die,
but they have other stuff there. And I found crystal meth and all this stuff.
And uh, by the time I, I left that trip,
I had a layover San Francisco and I was so physically sick from that
week. I had been in a car accident. I had smoked meth for a few days.
I was just, I was in so much physical anguish that when I got to San Francisco,
I really needed to get down like three or four Jack and diets to make the flight
to LA. And I had been in AA at that point.
So I'm so afraid someone from AA is going to run
into me at this airport.
And so I'm hiding in the corner of this bar and there's the proverbial mirror
actually was there and I'm, I'm,
I'm hiding and I am people recognized me.
So that dream had come true. Um,
I was about to make the most amount of money I ever made in my life,
starting that movie and amount of money that I thought would solve all things.
And I was the most scared, most depressed,
most suicidal I had ever been with all the things I had wanted to get.
And that was a very, very scary moment. And I realized, wow,
it really isn't about those things.
I had told myself as I think a lot of people do. Like if I got some money,
I'd be happy. If I got this girl, I'd be happy. If I got this job, I'd be happy.
And I was lucky enough to get to all those things. And I was very unhappy.
And so I really had to ask why,
and I had to actually figure out how to be happy. Cause it wasn't those things.
They help for sure. I don't want them to be taken away, but,
but I was at my point, uh, with all the things I had set out to get.
Where did you land.
And asking those questions in terms of what makes you happy?
What were the levers that mattered? What were the ingredients that mattered?
Well, I've slowly cobbled together. A little checklist for me. I think,
uh, a shame I just had a decade of shames, you know,
all kinds of deplorable behaviors while up.
Um, so that was a big component. And then really self-esteem right.
I was trying to get my value from a lot of outside
validation and then I got it and I just D I saw the same person in the mirror.
I'd also dated girls that I was convinced if that girl liked me. Well,
clearly that would prove I was desirable and worthy of wanting.
And then every time I'd look in the mirror, their house, I same piece of.
And so over years of being sober,
my lists really became, have I exercised?
I can't put too fine. A point on my belief in exercise. I like, uh, I'm a, uh,
a zealot about it. I I'm annoying. I, if I had to pick one thing in my life,
it would be that I exercise.
I've just never felt worse after an hour of exercise than I felt before.
So exercise is huge. Um, you know, have I gone to a meeting? That's huge.
Have I been of service to somebody I don't want to be. Uh,
and in general, when I feel terrible, if I asked myself those three things,
if those three things happened today, they've never happened.
I've never done those three things. And, and, and,
and been in major discontent. I, you know,
that for me is kind of my checklist.